però tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che solo
video sono farisei oggi salta di su for
guys con i ragazzi più forti del mondo
su questo gioco e io non dire che faccio
il ridicolo
non ha senso visto che anche io l'ultima
volta non ho vinto da tutti volta s'è
arrivati in finale ma che ci penso
quindi abbiamo però un lupo
oggi sei un lupo e sei cattivo va bene
allora avere almeno il secondo di gioco
ap almeno secondo è il minimo almeno
sindacale ma no signore serate vero
abbastanza male però il male anche per
gli altri e questo che fa testo capito
anche per gli altri non lo so che ti
senti certe
quindi tu basta che ti concentri
contenuti politici che sono più forte
l'ex coach la fai brava fair esigua dai
ma bravissima brava di subite alla fine
però non sto facendo però bravissima vai
vai vai vai vai a questo questo blu a
sinistra per tutto a sinistra
ok no non tutta sitar inadeguata questo
sto puntando ok a destra destra ad
essere poi team asd statista di strani
tra e tuffati brava bene se adesso te di
fermo io
trattenuto per due ore credo che se
tutto è andato come previsto almeno la
metà sono eliminati
non è andato una mazza come previsto
perfetto ma vinceva fare con lo slang
scommetti no ecco qui ormai oltre di era
difficile con un no non opere non lo è
basta che non cadi non si fatica ma se
non ti spingono non è non è difficile
non ti devi far ridere però non avere
l'ansia che rimano rimane limitato solo
a cadere nello slam ok allora non avesse
usato tutti sul giallo siamo veramente
tanti comunque vada veri che tutti
saltano sul giallo e molti vengono idee
ma infatti qua verranno eliminate un
sacco di persone fino a tempo perché la
gente lo prende come la prende come
torneo di velocità e non serve non è
quello scopo
no non ci sono ok ok ok ok ci siete
ragazzi come stati molto bravi del
livello step by calmo calmo basta che
non ti fai spingere perché ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta cioè fatta tranquilli raga
tranquilli non ne viene eliminato
nessuno buon ultimo perché non cadete
non lo slime bravo step di segue dove
sei perse più avanti brava per sé che
emozione bravissimo è tranquillo stai
tranquillo bravo va bene questo è il
peggior ero davvero a me cara calmati
calmati bravo
l'ultimo bravi ragazzi bravi bravi
così si gioca bravissimi piace tutta
brava gente reining quanto quanto ora
fine 12 10 11 10 11 11 11 potrebbe far
fare o la finale oro cat league perché
ci metterà finale può essere speriamo di
no perché non vuoi fare una finale
così extra con speriamo sia hexagon
teniamo noto il monte polmoni e quella
che odio di più in assoluto è orribile
seca di una volta hai perso
mamma mia che ansia di vivere sto gioco
che ansia sono caduto perso forse no
forse un errore lo fanno tutti un errore
lo fanno tutti si aiuto bravo stef bravo
bravo bravissimo
vai vai nostro saluto mai il tifo per te
va bene va benissimo bye bye bye bye bye
non sbagliare un bravissimo lo corri
corri nostro perché perché bellissimo
bravi però mi siete piaciuti dai next
one
arriviamo ad hexagon come finale ve lo
spiego potete forse anche vincere perché
una volta che vi spiega la tattica di
hexagon è molto più semplice di quello
che sembra
qualche rissa con la vedeva allora
questo è il gate crash ragazzi lo
ricordate vi sbagliate e solo il
tempismo ok perfetto brava per navalmare
va bene basta che rotoli nella parte
giusta bravissima ricordatevi di saltare
alla fine saltate che può un casino
matera che sì sì sì sì bravo ha detto ti
vedo per avere titano brava bene te
secondo mini gioco iniziale passato
tutti e tre miracolosamente bravi
ragazzi mi piacete passi avanti ragazzi
adesso mi iscrivo subito al torneo
mondiale di volgari servili di scrittura
manca un quarto non andate nel mezzo al
finale quando ci sono le allora ci sono
le tre palle quelle che roteano le tre
palle che roteano potete passare senza
tuffarvi senza niente tanto non mi
beccano se passato era una vale l'altra
è la prima palla questa qua tuffatevi ok
basta questo tutto ok qua ci passi
scorrendo correndo correndo isia qua non
io ma allora qua passi normalmente
quella dopo non in mezzo a ogni mezzo
perché guarda questo in mezzo come viene
spazzato guarda e visto che non serve a
niente a niente ti tuffi dall'ultima
para quella gigante
in tanti tutti lievi tuffateci arrivato
secondo o terzo il problema è che ogni
volta che arrivo dai dai dai che ci
siete ci siete stufati li tuffati no
ragazzi è facilissimo volta è
facilissimo vi vedo porca miseria parte
nostra
si no
ma io volevo portarvi tantino solo in
dieci sono stati eliminati
tra questi 10 dai e dai vediamo se
portare avanti la gloria maledetta jump
club è più molto più difficile di quello
che sembra molto più facile perché tante
volte sembra che ce la fa invece poi ti
spazza via fortissimo questo qua anche
maledetto perchè non è a tempo ea
eliminazioni di gente che viene spazzata
via tutto il testo è stato eliminato
meno male meno male poi mi fa ridere la
gente che mi grappa per chi non trova il
tempo di lavare la gente c'è già è tanto
sulla barra che causa gravi non è grave
piuttosto è perfetto urca ce l'ho fatta
anche la sera due però che è grande
dodici le mining and the non lo so in
realtà spero non sia la finale che ha
veramente a 12 nov ma deve essere se non
si ha la montagna spero che non sia la
montagna no perché la montagna e la opel
hanno aumentato rated alla montagna
adesso è fa schifo la odio la montagna
preferisco hexagon che quello con le
celle tipo delle api libero è orribile
perché non c'è tattica va culo invece in
hexagon c'e tattica niente o erano
essere regolamentato rete di stampa
strano almeno sam prima linea
significato diventava beh vediamo se
provo ricovero caduto
ok allora la palla che arriva qua ci
prende in pieno tutti quanti non
sapresti che io cado perché a questo qui
bianco non è caduto
ok ok per come fa essere lì come può
essere rilanciato viene tranciato lo zio
che è male poi solo a me ha peccato
confido nelle palle dei materiali
martelli strada peggiore martelli sono
maledetti niente appunto il giallo
laggiù che corre ma di fatto però
sì sì la nostra miseria far niente io
fall montella detesto perché poi io cado
gli altri non cadono il formont e non so
come mai
ragazzi siete stati molto bravi sono
fiero di voi per questo episodio
bravissimi a me siete migliorati canto
secondo me potete migliore ancora
comunque vedremo nei prossimi ancora
ragazzi di the place non consap è stata
anche la loro canale che trovate
iniziare gli scheletri anche al mio e
lasciate tasto mi piace non è piaciuto
il video e anche qualche commento se
avete voglia era come se ci vediamo e
ragazzi
[Musica]